hey Connor Brian here with yet another
clueless gamer today I'll be playing
Middle Earth shadow of war I'm happy
because I'm here with a friend a very
good friend star of the big sick Kumail
Nanjiani Kumail yes cool man
he has the forbidden stone of glorp gorg
are you are you a fan of this stuff a
little I am I love fantasy and I love
The Lord of the Rings stuff okay so me
mocking it probably is very insulting to
you and all you hold dear no it's not my
religion I just like it okay I think
what we're gonna do now is learn about
this game Aaron would you come on in
yeah alright sorry hey it's the worst
entrance in the history of show can you
stir it in like a rap yeah one of the
coolest things about this game is
there's a system called the Nemesis
system and that means that all the
enemies are dynamically generated so if
I started games to me enemies are gonna
be totally different from your enemies
you seem genuinely generated nobody's
ever given accessing the phrase
dynamically generated all day in the
bathroom this is these are all the guys
who we're gonna go up against look at
that dazed by seeing a brutal attack or
a shaming
he hates quitter you know the thing is
nothing's up to code in middle-earth you
have to have a railing there's me I mean
yeah
you can't just build that and that's a
Thai restaurant we're headed toward like
wherever rot nah you know it looks like
the best PF Changs gonna be that comes
ahead hit it hit why in a why
hey present that button thing is gonna
happen against 1x it's still going
killed by a strong I got you
that's a pretty accurate recap of yes
evening Joe do you want me to do it yes
I want you to take over okay I was bad
at that okay go ahead this is like
watching MOOCs or play the piano it's so
clear to me that you've never been
outside believe in playing these games
you could reveal the Intel ya get intel
on the drunk guy we have Intel just
knowing he's a drunk he has low
self-esteem
doesn't love his family doesn't love as
well probably loves his family but
doesn't know how to show it I'm so
covers that up with alcohol in a way I
have what should I do in him shave him
that's how you shame people right you
get hold their faith yes I have a guess
it hasn't been good welcome back to the
green room and I'd hold their head and I
just say your story that's how I get my
power all right so we shame them for
this character here dudes the agonizer
mm-hmm that's me I did the voice of this
guy you do the voice of dude the
agonising hey thanks fantastic that's a
high that's up like for you that must be
a lifelong dream right yeah that's very
exciting
he was the weird thing Conan I'm a
little nervous because did they it's
like a they wrote funny lines for me and
the lines actually are funny oh you're
like a comic relief sort of character
you're supposed to be kind of funny yeah
sometimes doesn't play well in the video
game dad said I'm afraid of wow that
because people really get into these
games and then you're there going like
let's get some soup but good annoyed you
know you're doing that's exactly what
I'm afraid of my god but at least well
you're an orc yeah all right so you
probably have a really cool like tubes
agonizer so it'll be cool to hear your
voice okay you don't have a I'm just
loving Kumail your unnecessary tumbling
you just tumble for no reason I think by
too
why would it go Doron come here and try
to murder maybe maybe but over the phone
way in the background yeah what are you
saying something
Pied Piper needs funding this should be
big points for you right you're going to
be playing this game with friends and
then you're gonna go like oh yeah that's
me it's also usually when friends are in
something they're like that's my voice
and you don't believe it right Billy no
the nice thing is that there's no
mistaking that that it's you your
character should be called Kumail the
Ranji because it's it should just be you
wearing this jacket we brought in Mike
to the creative director of the game is
that right Mike that is correct okay and
you guys brought Kumail in and according
to Kumail you told him that you were
going to affect his voice so he sounded
more like an orc
yet when you listen to him he's just
Kumail he sounds exactly like an orc no
he doesn't
yes the artist just sounds racist yes
racism is that O'Rourke's anyone from
another country sounds like an orc to
you
something can work right now would you
like to pay them again no I don't want
to be in this game unless you affect my
voice or else I'll be walking around
going oh it's rainy getting moist I know
we gotta find me here we go okay that is
a long jump and I'm going to put your
head on a pike what you think is another
word for spirit they've made it slightly
different I'm not sure you did nothing
okay can I swear on this yeah bro I
think he sounds right oh I wonder
wisecrack as the torso was falling yeah
you're wasting my time
Camille you're an amazing gamer he
really is he really you were I thought
you were incredible and the voice-acting
yeah so anyway the world war released on
October 10th on Xbox Playstation and PC
now I'm guessing that's code for
personal computer huh and they think I
don't know about
you